[Applause]
drake's
coming into the bubble i think really
yeah so the bubble is in orlando there's
a couple things going on that are quite
interesting um
the bubble in orlando they call it a
bubble because literally no one in no
one out
right so the bubble is this for the nba
uh playoffs the end of the season and
play yes they're about to happen
in orlando where the entire league is
going to go to this place in orlando no
one in noah now
and a massive problem is
and apparently this is what all the
players are asking about
yeah obviously i don't even need you to
finish this [ __ ]
these guys even if they are married are
just
tearing through [ __ ] on the road they
got side chicks in every city
and i'm not snitching everybody but we
all know what the [ __ ] time it is guys
just pick up a book
so if you're in the bubble they're not
going to be flying [ __ ] in and out
that's locked in
so the dudes are rightfully asking you
are we supposed to go two months without
[ __ ] that being said you're gonna get
the best play that you've ever had i
mean it's gonna be super aggressive
maybe it's gonna be back in 80s where
they were just swinging imagine the most
testosterone induced human beings on the
planet
not being able to let that testosterone
out it's like jailball
it's jailball dude this is gonna be the
replacements or whatever that movie was
oh yeah was it the replacements uh any
longest yard
longest yard yeah so they're gonna be in
there but a big issue is with the girls
and then
i heard a rumor that drake might be
coming into the bubble
hmm breaking news yeah so maybe we get
drake and that's a bubble
and i i actually think it's a smart move
on drake's part yep
but drake ain't gonna be able to go two
months without getting [ __ ] dre gonna
be bringing [ __ ] in and out
so he doesn't have to stay the whole
time the rules right
no i think he's got i think everybody
there the person that is going to come
up the most
are these [ __ ] that are working like
the chicken tender uh
machine you know what i mean they're
filling coconuts
yo i'm saying if you have a job in
orlando working in the bubble and you're
a girl
you are gonna catch yourself a ball
player you might not get pregnant but
you definitely gonna get some dick and
you're gonna be [ __ ]
way out of your league because you're
the only [ __ ] in the bubble son
you better do what you can to be the
baddest tender [ __ ] son
yeah fry them up [ __ ] tinder this
tenders this tender dog
i wonder if the cheerleaders are going
to go down because they're going to get
smug
that's the solution is you bring quietly
like a set number of hoes in and that's
just these are the [ __ ] for the two
months if you
are a dude in orlando and talk to your
family members
if you are due in orlando they got a
girlfriend that's working in a bubble
and she's like babe i can't see you for
the next couple months i got to work in
a bubble
kiss that [ __ ] she belongs to the
bubble she belongs
it's over yo you girls getting [ __ ]
cracked
i was trying i was gonna do a sound
effect but i couldn't think of one
except the whip
but some of them look like whips i bet
do you know
more like details or rules with this
bubble situation nobody ain't nobody out
i think once you leave you're gone
there's gonna be some people ready to
lose out that [ __ ]
oh let's get the [ __ ] up out here man if
you if you
know you're not gonna be able to beat
the lakers if you know you're not gonna
beat
you know the [ __ ] uh raptors or
whatever you might as well just
leave and get some [ __ ] lakers clippers
is going to be the only good series
because
lebron and kawaii are the only guys who
want to win everybody else like get me
home yo i'm trying to get back to these
[ __ ] yeah
dude lebron is like yeah i don't got
that much time left i could put it on
hold for two months also probably he
could get girls in and out nobody gonna
say [ __ ]
and kawhi he doesn't have sexual
feelings anyway
he's just a robot it is interesting
though that lebron shut down all that
we're not gonna play talk
y'all right there are a few players
talking about that hey man we we
shouldn't play keep the focus on the
issues
old brooklyn nets the whole nets and
then lebron was like y'all ain't in the
playoffs anyway with your bum asses
you're going to be protesting protesting
is for you
there's no families in the bubble either
i think whoever comes in stays
like can you bring your family i don't
know um i gotta look
i gotta look do some [ __ ] like that i
think they just fly in
as many holes as they can there's just
gonna be a house for the hose
that's what you gotta do yeah and you
can't make it public that's the problem
is keeping it quiet everybody gonna run
their [ __ ] mouth
but quietly you need to bring in 30 to
100 [ __ ]
and then just these this is your job son
this is what epstein did
i mean they were too young obviously you
know what i'm saying
but that's essentially what they were
organizing legal i've seen legalizing
you need a legal epstein
think about it think about it make
people territorial they're like oh
that's my side piece like
nah a little bit but then y'all can hash
that out on the court they share all the
hoes
they share a hose butt because there's
an abundance of hoes
when you have a limited number of hoses
finite hose
finite hose is a problem someone's got
to organize
these hoes hey hey want you [ __ ] why
don't you much yourself to that bubble
go park in that [ __ ]
you want to be [ __ ] go walk to the
[ __ ] bubble bro whose job is it to
organize the hundred or so hoes
a [ __ ] march to the hotel that's what
you need you put them up in a hotel
put them up a magic kingdom they could
play in the [ __ ] resorts
all day or play in the what a harry
potter world
i'm just saying that's universal yo
what's that part of the bubble that's
not a part of the bubble
oh i ain't going this [ __ ] could be
an animal kingdom the way they finna get
dogged out
it's an interesting thing and it's going
to be interesting to see how things play
out i wonder if people start to get real
angry
oh first game july 30th when is this
supposed to oh july 30th first game but
they're like
i'm gonna be looking at some of these
instagram hoes i'm gonna see you see
where they at oh did you see any girl
posting near a mickey mouse
sound ain't gonna be no posting she for
the street no she's for the bubble
pay attention to the [ __ ] not posting
oh cause they're the ones that are in
the bubble and you can't let anybody
know you're if a [ __ ] stops posing she
only posts like
in the gym in the hotel yeah in a hotel
bedroom
she's a bubble [ __ ]
that [ __ ] a bubble oh that's a title
yo damn this is it's like all-star
weekend
but but for a month yeah do you think
these girls could take it
how are they gonna get their birth
control in the bubble how are they gonna
get their day after pill somebody gonna
get all that [ __ ] there drake
that's on drake drake gotta come through
with a louis vuitton bag a day after
right you put that [ __ ] in the breakfast
buffet right at the end of it next to
the bread you know you can get the bagel
you put in the toaster machine
right next to that birth control that's
good and there's a
setup right there everybody's taking two
months of birth control down there like
that's just nice
not even a question you gotta bro and
then you just crack an ass actually to
be honest these [ __ ] ain't taking no
birth control there
they're trying to they're trying to get
got yeah i think that's why you need to
test these [ __ ] for covid
and you need to touch them for that the
you you not uti iud
yeah oh yo you got to be iud you got to
be i you deed up
you get deed down you know what i mean
get that chip in your arm you could put
a chip in these girls on like they're a
dog
you could chip a girl [ __ ] behind her
shoulder you put it no they put it right
in this muscle right here so every time
she jerks off she remembers
every time she jerked that dick she see
that chip
you should be able to see that [ __ ] pop
out real talk you should be able to tap
your dick on it like you're
uh putting food through the ringer at
the grocery store just like poop like
that
low-key you should be able to put your
balls on a chip and then zaps
all the sperm in your balls so you could
still let it out
but they don't swim paralyze them did i
just make some fire [ __ ] up
imagine you just take your balls on a
girl's arm and just boop
just imagine that akash what do you
usually do with your balls before sex
i do exactly that i don't know what
you're talking about you don't play no
games with your balls
no what you playing oh dude i always do
that [ __ ] tic-tac-toe what you playing i
don't know sometimes i like turn
i'll like squeeze them like that and
i'll turn them into a little butt
into a little butt you know because they
go like that oh you know what i mean or
some lips
you know what i'm saying but it's just
like some big lips like mine yeah and
then i'll just give a little kiss to my
girl
i'll just go like on her leg that's cute
you got no top legs yeah i don't know
what you got no top lip mark got better
lips than you man get out of here mark
ain't got no
lips he's also french bro you've been
sucking on baguettes his whole life
but not for real top lip i got a bigger
top lip than you
you can't even say come on cuz i'm
smiling when i smile it goes away
but when i'm not smiling when i'm
[ __ ] stone cold
oh dark
come on bro